gastadores incendios forestales en el
sur del continente americano unas 12.000
hectáreas fueron consumidas por el fuego
en la región de niebla en el sur de
chile varias casas quedaron destruidas
el que conectó colocando tanto puesto
así que
esa es de allá y esta
casa de al lado también del vecino las
autoridades movilizaron cuatro aviones y
cinco helicópteros junto a decenas de
efectivos de seguridad y bomberos pero
sólo pudo recordar la totalidad de las
viviendas en puntos determinados donde
llegamos a tener amenaza hasta alrededor
dentro de esas viviendas se suma una
tercera y las dos primeras teníamos
viviendas de veraneo ahora esta tercera
en una vivienda de personas que vivían
en el sector la oficina nacional de
emergencias del ministerio del interior
de chile indicó que 19 incendios estaban
activos en todo el país mientras que
otros 35 fueron asfixiados en la
patagonia argentina y tres incendios
activos en neuquén bariloche y tierra
del fuego la columna de humo dificulta
el trabajo de los bomberos seguimos en
la patagonia con más de 220 brigadistas
9 aviones y ocho helicópteros junto con
el trabajo de las provincias y
municipios en el combate del fuego los
incendios se deben a las altas
temperaturas y en la sequía que vive la
región desde hace dos años